tha
monsieur bonsoir à la suite d'un conflit
entre la rédaction antenne 2 et sa
direction ce journal ne vous sera pas
présentée dans les conditions normales
et je vous prie de nous en excuser
trois fois plus de pétrole que dans les
soutes du torrey canyon et cela se passe
à 5 km des côtes bretonnes 11 ans et oui
à 11 ans presque jour pour jour après la
catastrophe provoquée par le naufrage du
trop célèbre torrey canyon un pétrolier
échoué sur les récifs de la bri à la
bretagne nord est en train de polluer à
une vitesse grand v les côtes françaises
ce navire l'amoco cadiz s'est brisé
cette nuit sur les terribles roche de
portsall un joli petit port à 30 km au
nord-ouest de brest les parts est donc
coupée en deux et le pétrole a déjà
pollué plusieurs kilomètres des plages
voici l'amoco cadiz ou du moins ce qu'il
en reste
deux cent trente mille tonnes de pétrole
brut à bo3 qu ont déjà éclaté et un
tiers de la cargaison s'est répandue le
pétrolier avait quitté le golf persique
le 7 février dernier pour la grande
bretagne
c'est une avarie de gouvernail dit hier
en début de soirée qui est à l'origine
de l'échouage un bâtiment la priant
remords mais les vents violents et les
vagues de quatre à six mètres de haut
ont cassé le canot à la dérive
la maco cadix a éperonné la barrière
rocheuse au large de port st tandis que
les hélicoptères évacuer l'équipage
le pétrole a commencé à s'échapper le
plan paul mann l'équivalent du plan
orsec sur terre déclenché à minuit a
permis de mettre d'importants moyens en
place à brest
tous les bateaux disponibles ont
embarqué de la craie et des détergents
mail approche est pratiquement
impossible d recipe sont trop dangereux
pour l'instant c'est 50 à 60 mille
tonnes de pétrole qui touche la zone
sinistrée
entre portal et l'aber benoît et l'on
craint qu'elle ne s'étende encore les
vents et les vagues risquent en effet de
briser totalement l'épave du pétrolier
et c'est alors 220 mille tonnes de
pétrole qui se répandrait sur toutes les
côtes du finistère nos une région déjà
sensibilisé puisqu'il ya deux ans dans
ce secteur
c'est chouette l'olympique prat vrai
alors les pêcheurs content atterrés les
côtes
devant ce qui apparaît déjà comme la
plus grande catastrophe écologique
bien sûr si près c'est prévisible
ça c'est une histoire de gros sous dans
la passion pour la bonne raison que on
devrait interdire la proche des coptes
qui coûtent très fréquentés comme c'est
le cas de la pointe de bretagne à des
navires de ce genre l'espace est
suffisamment grand il devrait les faire
passer au minimum de 50 nautiques décote
est bien balisé des secteurs al'approche
des ports où ils doivent décharger leur
cargaison
je vous laisse imaginer la rage au coeur
des bretons bien que le plan polmar on
vous l'a dit et ai été immédiatement
déclenché bien que le sauvetage sont
aussitôt engagé mais une fois de plus on
se pose les mêmes questions que faisait
ce pétrolier si près des côtes et
surtout peut-on indéfiniment permettre
que de tels mastodontes battant pavillon
de complaisance circulent en faisant fi
des réglementations internationales eu
d'accord c'est fait à la et le 2 mars
dernier qui permettra à tous ses états
de prendre un certain nombre de mesures
préventives
c'est à dire en particulier d'inspecter
les navires dans les ports de s'informer
mutuellement des défectuosités et le cas
échéant de bloquer les navires les
empêcher de partir s'il ne respecte pas
les normes minimales ne serait-il pas
préférable d'obliger les super tanker au
large d'ouessant à prendre un pilote de
haute
mais faut-il imposer un pilote je ne
suis pas sûr que le pilote permettrait
d'éviter certaines pannes sur le navire
et dans le cas malheureusement que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est une panne
qui s'est produite sur le navire il est
encore trop tôt pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusions de cet accident
mais je ne suis pas sûr que le pilotage
hauturier puisse permettre d'éviter de
telles pannes encore peu la présence à
bord d'un homme qualifié dainville
autres qualifiés puisse être une
garantie de sécurité appréciable et dans
le cas de l'amoco cadiz y aurait
peut-être une autre solution c'est de
repousser vers le large
le couloir de passage ses couloirs ne
sont déjà pas très près puisqu'ils sont
à quelques milles au large tous les
cendres et la france a proposé à l'opci
à l'organisation maritime consultative
internationale qui 1,6 organismes dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure dans le
cadre de menus à proposer donc de
repousser si route en même temps que de
les élargir
la décision a été prise et doit être
mise en application au cours des
prochains mois l'actualité l'étranger
reste bien entendu dominé par les suites
de l'enlèvement d'aldo moro ce matin les
deux viandes rouges ont lancé un nouvel
ultimatum en menaçant de tuer l'ancien
président du conseil avant ce soir
si les détenus de turin détenus vous
savez appartenant aux mêmes brigades
rouges n'étaient pas libérés au delà de
l'indignation delà de la peur qui a
physiquement réellement pris à la gorge
une grande partie de nos voisins toutes
tendances politiques confondues
il est aussi une crainte pour la vie
d'aldo moro on a retrouvé la voiture qui
avait servi à son enlèvement
et il y avait du sang sur les coussins
alors avec nous en direct aux côtés de
victor vraiment giancarlo palette payet
acquis et le numéro d'un deux du parti
communiste italien
dans ce but le journal d'antenne 2 un
responsable de la démocratie chrétienne
nous expliquer que ce terrorisme cette
situation d'urgence qui s'écrit en
l'italie n'était pas une raison
suffisante pour la formation d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale avec la
participation des communistes alors je
voulais vous poser la même question
monsieur payette à est-ce que vous
pensez que cette situation
accélérer la formation d'un gouvernement
en italie avec la participation des
communistes mais je pense que pour nous
c'est ce n'est pas le problème
pour nous le problème c'est que le
gouvernement qui était est fait et
maintenant bien que nous avons décrit
que affaires commencent à gouverner
c'est pour cela que hier la chambre des
députés le sénat lui ont donné la
confiance nous avons besoin d'un
gouvernement qui puisse faire son
dévoile sous le contrôle avec l'aide de
démocratie des forces démocratiques dans
ce moment même nous sommes en train de
parler et de président du conseil
à près de lui et notre secrétaire
général éric oberling world avec les
secrétaires généraux des autres partis
il ce n'est pas un gouvernement ce n'est
pas un cabinet mais c'est une chose qui
est pour la première fois depuis des
années et des années donne au
gouvernement une autorité qui n'a jamais
aidé en ce moment l'autorité c'est
nécessaire pour le mobiliser des forces
qui assurent la démocratie dans le pays
nos autorités qui vient de l'unité c'est
payet est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression un petit peu que c'est le
parti communiste qui est visé le parti
communiste qui vous le disais est en
train d'accepter une partie de
responsabilité au pouvoir
mais le parti communiste à 2 hier
pression de wall a participé réponse
unitaire et démocratique comme l'italie
n'a jamais bu hier l'italie n'est pas
seulement vécu journée
pour les agents de police qui ont été
tués de craintes pour la sorte d'un
démocrate comme un monsieur mort mais
elle a trouvé la force d'être dans la
rue il ya une grève générale comme on
n'avait jamais vu mais ces dernières
années je crois qu'elle y terrier a
démontré que l'unité et la présence de
communistes comme une force décisive à
un ré j'étais pas seulement le
terrorisme de gauche
mallet tentative d'exploiter cela de
l'appart de la droite et même ceux qui
dans les jours qui sont passés ont
cherché d'un pc l'unité la formation
d'une nouvelle majorité
on était comme balayé ils ont même
refusé au mieux ils n'ont pas osé et ni
à la chambre de députés ni au sénat de
parler si il était membre de la
démocratie chrétienne et pour ceux que
les gars ben les fassis théine ont fait
quelque chose qui était pitoyable et
absolument sans signification n'est un
poids politique monsieur payet avoue
communiste démocrate chrétien socialiste
vous êtes tous unis dans l'épreuve bien
entendu mais vous n'avez pas
l'impression que la démocratie italienne
une façon générale est en train de
mourir tout doucement sous les coups de
boutoir de l'extrême droite et de
l'extrême gauche auto mais nous sommes
unis et je dirais et dans le même temps
qu'est et il doit y être est un plus
grand de l'unité parce que les
démocrates chrétiens on démontait de ne
pas avoir compris la gravité de la
situation
j'aime ce pays et n'ont dû reconnaître
que sans les communistes
on ne peut pas sauver la démocratie
c'est une force décisive notre unité
avec les socialistes
épreuve qui s'est bien passé maintenant
il s'agit de faire que tout cela devient
de fait concrète
les gens veulent être assurés de leur
avenir jeudi les mêmes de leurs by
thierry payet à jour merci beaucoup
d'avoir été auprès de nous à antenne 2
dans un moment difficile pour l'italie
et je vous propose de revoir avec nous
maintenant et avec qui tu auras mans ce
que fut le film de cette journée
d'aujourd'hui donc marqué par les suites
de l'enlèvement de monsieur aldo moro
dont on a je voulais dit tout à l'heure
retrouvé la voiture en tout cas la
voiture qui a servi à cet enlèvement et
qui j'oubliais étaient tâchés de sang
donc on n'a pas de nouvelles pour
l'instant sur la santé de monsieur
moreau
il
aujourd'hui encore et pendant toute la
journée des dizaines de romain anonymes
ont déposé des fleurs là où ont été tués
les cinq gardes du corps d'aldo moro
cela se fait spontanément c'est un
hommage aux victimes
mais c'est aussi une protestation contre
le terrorisme un millier d'hommes
policiers carabiniers ont perquisitionné
dans la zone où habitait aldo morts
d'après la police
non seulement les ravisseurs n'auraient
pas quitté rome mais matériellement il
n'aurait pas eu la possibilité de
s'éloigner du quartier où est effectué
et l'enlèvement
le ratissage est systématique les
carabiniers portent des gilets pare
balles s'il découvre un repaire des
brigades rouges du son sur que les
terroristes se défendront jusqu'au bout
ce déploiement de force a pour but de
retrouver les ravisseurs d'aldo mort
mais aussi de rassurer la population
ce qui est certain maintenant c'est que
le gouvernement ne cédera pas aux
exigences des brigades rouges
madame auront la femme du président de
la démocratie chrétienne l'a confirmé
pas question de traiter avec les
ravisseurs qui semble-t-il ont déjà
réclamé la libération d'une quinzaine de
détenus
la police est partout dans les rues de
rome
on contrôle les voitures pour le moment
les résultats sont maigres
on insiste aujourd'hui sur la
ressemblance entre l'enlèvement d'aldo
morts et celui de hans martin schleich
l'industriel allemand mêmes méthodes
expéditives sanglante de la part des
terroristes
ce matin une voix anonyme a appelé la
radio italienne
nous sommes des baader meinhof et un
texte en allemand a été dicté les
brigades rouges ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient envoyer une photo d'aldo moro
et que celui ci était détenu dans une
prison du peuple là encore on retrouve
les mêmes procédés que dans le cas de
l'enlèvement de sly
les autorités ont riposté
comme l'ont fait les allemands les
photographies d'une vingtaine de
terroristes ont été diffusés à la
télévision et publient dans certains
journaux
les italiens sont invités à téléphoner
un certain endroit au cas où ils
auraient des renseignements
cette méthode n'a soulevé aucune
protestation pour quelqu'un qui vit en
italie
ce qui frappe ce n'est pas tellement la
psychose de l'enlèvement ou de
l'attentât c'est plutôt une sorte de
mobilisation des esprits contre le
terrorisme il y a réellement unanimité
et cohésion entre les partis politiques
les syndicats
la presse est l'homme de la rue oui il
faut savoir que malgré tout ce passe
bien le procès de turin se poursuivra
bien lundi comme prévu
savoir aussi que de partout afflux de
l'étranger surtout des télégrammes de
sympathie et des déclarations indignées
chacun en france notamment et c'est d'en
tirer argument pour ses propres opinions
politiques et notamment donc en france
où majorité et opposition se disputent
les interpellations de cet enlèvement en
france maintenant à deux jours du
deuxième jour des du deuxième tour
pardon des législatives la classe
politique c'est un moment arrêter de
polémiquer pour rendre hommage à un
homme public respecté de tous andré
boulloche car ce que nous pressentions
hier soir au tout début de ce journal
c'est hélas confirmer on a bien retrouvé
l'appareil disparu d'andré bloch et de
son pilote et deux passagers du petit
avion était mort en allemagne
pas très loin de la frontière le chef de
l'état adressé un télégramme de
condoléances à la veuve du député maire
de montbéliard
je rends hommage dit il à la mémoire du
compagnon la libération de l'ancien
ministre du parlementaire dont le sens
de l'état l'engagement politique et la
rectitude morale ont toujours été la
règle de conscience c'était dimanche
dernier dans l'un des bureaux de vote de
montbéliard ville dont andré boulloche
était le maire depuis 13 ans député de
la deuxième circonscription du doubs
depuis 1967 il est tête à l'issue du
premier tour en ballottage favorable
andré boulloche et est âgé de 62 ans
polytechnicien ingénieur général des
ponts et chaussées il fut ministre du
général de gaulle en 1958 puis ministre
de l'éducation nationale jusqu'en 1959
dans le cabinet de monsieur michel debré
membre du comité directeur du parti
socialiste il était plus
particulièrement chargé des questions
financières et avait présenté à ce titre
le plan socialiste chiffrées
la philosophie de nos propositions c'est
de deux éléments d'une part combattre la
justice devenu insupportable du fait de
la crise la justice exige depuis fort
longtemps et il faut se rendre compte
qu'une crise comme celle que nous
traversons abouti à la faire peser d'une
façon de plus en plus lourde et
finalement insupportable sur certaines
catégories de la population
c'était le 14 février 1978
andré boulloche était compagnon de la
libération c'était aussi un ami
personnel de françois mitterrand et il y
à quelques minutes j'apprenais que
monsieur boulloche et son pilote n'était
sans doute pas mort sur le coup il
semble que les deux hommes grièvement
blessés
ce soit d'abord abrité dans une cabane
proche de l'endroit où l'appareil s'est
écrasé mais les secours ne sont pas
arrivés à temps tout cela se passait
donc sans doute milliards soit au moment
où se diffuser ce journal et cela rend
bien sûr cette fin encore plus tragique
au même moment françois mitterrand
interrogé par nos confrères du club de
la presse d'europe 1 se refusait à
croire à la disparition de son ami dont
il a évoqué les qualités en solitaire en
club de la presse hier soir vous suivent
le moins ubuesque quand on prononce ces
deux mots andré boulloche c'est un salut
à quelqu'un d'assez exceptionnel sur
tous les plans certaines ont trente noms
connus au retour de déportation pas la
résistance
voilà c'est un homme exemple et c'est ce
que je pensais récemment alors que j'ai
vite et avec moi des prévenus ce voyage
dont il m'avait parlé voilà l'homme
exemple voici tout ce que je peux dire
il allait sans doute dans d'autres
partis que la nôtre et ce serait
vraiment mal me connaître que de preuves
jour identifié avantage dans moins de
quatre heures maintenant fin de la
campagne électorale officielle les jeux
sont toujours indécis d'autant que la
loi interdit la publication de tout
sondage
mais je vous indique tout de suite que
vous serez les premiers informés après
demain soir dimanche sur les résultats
de ce deuxième tour puisque à 20h face
is la c2i honeywell bull fournira une
estimation qui devrait être aussi exact
le dimanche dernier notre soirée sera
composé de la même façon que la dernière
fois c'est à dire en direct de l'hôtel
de lassay
avec les rédactions d'europe 1 une
antenne 2 animé par etienne mougeotte et
jean pierre elkabbach
alors en attendant cette échéance est
bien bien sûr les grands leaders
politiques se sont exprimés pour la
dernière fois
par exemple jean lecanuet qui pour l'udf
était notre dernier invité à 12h45
jean lecanuet qui a répondu à nos
questions en cas de victoire de la
majorité valérie labbé stade peut-il
compter sur une vraie majorité qui
soutiendra sa politique
la réponse de jean letienne et si la
majorité comme nous souhaitons le
voulons nous le croyons gagne les
élections dimanche soir il y aura un
vainqueur et c'est le président de la
république lui même et je crois que le
fait d'être le vainqueur d'élections si
difficile jugé il ya peu de temps encore
si incertaine si douteuses lui donnera
un surcroît d'autorité et qu'il pourra
fixer les directives au premier ministre
qui sera nommé dans les jours qui
suivront
quignard des ventes aux chaînes
parlementaires jaune a toujours un peu
mais quel est l'homme politique le
groupement politique ou même la fraction
groupements politiques qui oserait
mettre en difficulté le président de la
république après ces sélections non
quelles que soient les arrière-pensées
que certains prêtent à tel ou tel
je crois qu'il y aura une forte cohésion
de la majorité derrière le vainqueur
derrière le président de la république
alors toujours du côté de la majorité
christian bonnet a estimé à privas en
ardèche que françois mitterrand était
minoritaire au sein de la gauche
françois mitterrand que nous avons suivi
hier soir dans le xviiie arrondissement
à paris et qui a évoqué le climat disons
tendu qui règne en ce moment on cherche
à déformer la connaissance on cherche à
fabriquer
préfabriqué des consciences on cherche à
embrigader un peuple derrière des mots
d'ordre et des slogans
la fin justifiant tous les moyens bref
au nom de la démocratie
on ouvre la voie à ce que j'ai connu
lorsque j'avais 20 ans et qui s'appelait
tout simplement parce qu'il ne portait
pas d'autre nom mensonge organisé
informations trafic et tout voir de
linchamps fanatisme de la société
dirigeante et qui s'appelait le fascisme
qu'est-ce qui manque créé si nous
apportons l'entousiasme la conviction
l'union la capacité de rassembler les
forces populaires nous gagnerons
si nous le voulons
enfin dernier des grands leaders à
s'exprimer raymond barre qui comme la
semaine dernière tenait son dernier
meeting à lyon c'est à dire dans sa
nouvelle circonscription
il ya en france des électeurs et des
électrices communiste
indépendamment de la machine
indépendamment du parti ce sont des
françaises et des français
ils ont leur opinion nous devons les
respecter et je serai le premier à
m'élever contre toute mesure qui privait
pour une raison politique les électeurs
et les électrices qu'une certaine
tendance en france à ne plus disponibles
et priverait du droit d'association du
droit de réunion du droit d'expression
mais de même qu'il ne souhaite pas au
parti communiste
que nous soyons au gouvernement nous
avons bien le droit de ne pas souhaiter
que soit ouverte ou raymond barre qui a
depuis ce soir philippe sassier trois
nouveaux chiffres en main effectivement
il ya eu trois résultats économiques qui
ont été publiés aujourd'hui de bons et
inquiète un petit peu moins bon les
vandales dans ce baromètre soul et de me
remettre rapidement le commerce
extérieur en février a été excédentaire
c'est la quatrième fois en six mois cela
confirme le nonce donc une tendance au
redressement du commerce extérieur
pourquoi ce redressement est bien et
semble que les produits français soit
plus compétitif à l'étranger notamment
en europe du reste nos exportations mois
de février ont augmenté de 6 et 9% où il
donc ça n'est pas négligeable
et puis enfin il semble que nos échanges
agroalimentaires qui avait été très
difficile terre au mois de janvier sont
redevenu excédentaire en février un don
voix se sont prononcées charles andrée
rosier deuxième résultat est bien la
production industrielle au mois de
février est en léger redressement là
aussi par rapport au mois de décembre on
ne peut pas parler vraiment de reprise
il ya pommiers des spécialistes allégé
frissonnement de la conjoncture quant au
troisième résultat il est effectivement
un petit peu moins bon il s'agit des
demandes d'emploi au mois de
ouvrier en augmentation en légère
augmentation corrigé des variations
saisonnières un million 42000 contre 1
millions 23 me en janvier
il faut dire que selon le ministère de
l'emploi cette légère augmentation est
due à une évolution cessionnaire
saisonnière que l'on constate
ordinairement il est vrai qu'en données
brutes et bien il y a une légère
diminution du chômage
le franchement rien maintenant deux
jours après l'intervention des troupes
israéliennes au sud liban il y a encore
quelques combats sur le terrain
cependant les forces de l'armée
israélienne sont arrivés à atteindre
leur objectif principal c'est à dire
relier entre elles les enclaves de leurs
alliés chrétiens et la population israël
la population attend elle maintenant eh
bien je les retombées politiques de
sorède
alors tout de suite sur place en israël
gerrard bague anita est un exemple de
ces kibboutz de ces agglomérations
israéliennes qui jouxte véritablement la
frontière avec le liban puisque cette
ligne de barbelés et l'emplacement qui
marque la séparation entre le liban et
israël
et c'est dans cette ligne de barbelés
que les israéliens ont aménagé de
véritables porte d'où ils peuvent
pénétrer au liban au début de l'eau
continue t il
rousse s'est totalement arrêté seuls les
combattants sur leurs blindés étaient
visibles dans les champs le long de la
frontière et si aujourd'hui il continue
à patrouiller à renforcer leurs
positions au sud liban où se déroulent
encore quelques combats des civils sam
enfants après 48 heures passées dans les
abris de béton ont repris leurs
activités mais pour eux aussi
spectaculaire qu'elle soit cette
opération n'est que modérément apaiser
leurs craintes
ce jardin ça va être efficace vu qu'il y
a quant à éliminer un certain nombre de
terroristes
c'est déjà de terroristes en moins 4 les
attaquants - le kibboutz ils attaqueront
moins dans toutes les villes en israël
mais efficace quant à dire que demain il
n'y aura plus aucun attentat et tous
c'est un peu difficile à dire ça parce
que j'y prends pas seulement
l'opposition travailliste
il n'a jamais osé lancer une telle
action à l'époque où elle se trouvait au
pouvoir soutient pourtant le
gouvernement de monsieur begin qui
explique la finalité de cette opération
aujourd'hui il ya deux ans d'action avec
anglet syrienne ls il faut terminer
l'été il y actuellement régnait il y a
aussi le vivrai mais avec les les
ukrainiens ne pas aucune question
nous sommes prêts quittait le bambara
chaque minute
le rugby maintenant à la veille de la
grande finale du tournoi des cinq
nations galles-france une bonne nouvelle
la france a été invité à faire partie de
lynch board
le board et bien c'est cette
l'association qui élabore les règles du
rugby et qui tranche les conflits entre
fédérations nationales antenne de bien
sûr retransmettra en direct de garder
cette finale dans l'émission les jeux du
stade pour nous et pour vous pierre
salviac à chausser ses crampons pour
faire un tour d'entraînement sur la
verte pelouse dans ce parc
ici commence l'enfer voici l'arms park
avec son nom de guerre ses allures de
forteresse et senans bien hausse
insoutenable quand cinquante mille
gallois représentant d'un peuple
roturier batailleur fier et poète chante
en choeur pour l'honneur d'une nation et
la victoire d'une équipe
ça fait dix ans que dans ce temple du
rugby les joueurs du pays de galles
n'ont pas perdu un match international
dix ans rendez vous compte un peu de
quoi flatter l'amour propre de ces
diables rouges que la ferveur
nationaliste pousse à l'exploit chaque
fois qu'il s'agit d'affirmer la
personnalité galloires car le rugby ici
voyez vous c'est avant tout une affaire
de coeur
quand je suis c'est le terrain en ce
parc compte encore deux jours pour pays
de galles par exemple il ya toujours
avant le match contre lille en salle
vide
l'hymne l'hymne du pays de galles tu
sais que c'est très difficile pour moi
de chanter je veux chanter de ces mets
toujours je pleure toujours tu sais
quand j'étais petit enfant de 8 ans chez
moi il y avait personne qui joue le
football parce que tout le monde joue et
je le réduis et moi je joue au rugby
comme tout le monde
voilà demain donc à 2 à 16 heures la
météo pour se terminer ce journal je
voulais déjà dit et bien la tempête qui
a régné sur notre pierre est à l'origine
de beaucoup de catastrophes et pour
demain les spécialistes sont assez
pessimistes dans l'est averses
accompagnées de neige en montagne et des
orages dans le midi ailleurs et bien des
éclaircies apparaîtront après les brumes
matinales mais il y aura aussi des vents
forts dans le midi et les températures
d'une façon générale seront en baisse
et puis il aura même des gelées dans
l'intérieur du pays voilà ce journal se
termine par don pour les conditions
techniques un petit peu fragile de ce
journal justifier je vous répète par un
conflit au sein de la formation en peine
de vous donne rendez-vous avec
l'actualité vers 23h25 avec un journal
présenté par gérard holtz je referme
celui ci et puis je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée l écoute de nos
programmes
bonsoir à lundi après le deuxième tour